a common narrative that you'll hear is
from feminism from progressives is that
the sexual revolution was a great idea
and it was a way of
counteracting
centuries of oppressive patriarchal
repression
and the problem is just that we haven't
i fully implemented it the the the
original idea to free everyone to
prioritize freedom above
all other values
was fabulous the problem is that we
haven't quite yet done it we need more
freedom we need to push that freedom
lever again and again and again until
everything comes right and i think that
was the error
i think actually
freedom is not the preeminent value i
think it has to be balanced against
other values
like what
restraint
[Music]
we don't like that word in the 21st
century
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kissin
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our terrific guest today is a
journalist and the author of the case
against the sexual revolution louise
perry welcome to trigonometry thank you
so much for having me it's really great
to have you on uh before we get into
what i'm sure will be a fascinating
conversation tell us uh who are you how
are you where you are what has been your
journey through life
my journey through life
well
i'm a journalist now
i wasn't always
my
first
well i'll start a little bit earlier
very briefly i'm born and bred in london
my family are australian
but i've always lived in the uk
um
i
as we were just talking about i did
anthropology at university
and then the first job that i did after
leaving university was working in a red
crisis center which i'm sure is going to
come up
in relation to the book
i did that for a couple of years and
then
i became a journalist freelancing
various places i now work for
a combination that people find
surprising i'm a columnist at the new
statesman and i also write for the day
mail
[Laughter]
it's true
um and this is my first book the case
against sexual revolution i'm also
um i'm press officer for a campaign
group called we can't consent to this
um and we campaign on um cases where
women have been murdered and men have
claimed they consented to be to legal
violence as part of rough sex
i'm sure again that's going to come up
because it all feeds into the book i
mean the the book in a way is a
culmination of
of
life experience and thinking over the
course of you know
10 years at least
and we've uh had a couple of people on
uh to talk about the problems with the
sexual revolution in the past
um and you know it's not a necessarily a
new critique uh what what the sort of
things that you're talking about but
generally it would it would be people
who sort of women wanted women back in
the kitchen that would people like me no
no but but you know what i mean you see
i'm saying that it was coming from a
certain angle and those that was the the
concern i don't think you're coming at
it from that angle so what is it that
you
have identified that has been the
negatives particularly for women out of
some of the changes we saw in the 60s
and and later yeah so as you say this is
quite a well-trodden path for religious
conservatives
in particular
um who tend to come at it as you say
from a different angle from me because i
am
you know for all of my heterodoxy i
suppose i am coming at this from
i say that i start with feminist priors
and i end up at some conservative
conclusions
although not all but some
in the sense that
i think that the sexual revolution from
the get-go
had downsides for women
you know not to say that anyone designed
it it's not a conspiracy you know it's a
culmination of a lot of different
historical accidents and individual
behavior or whatever but
um
the common narrative that you'll hear um
a lot nowadays is i think that people
are starting to recognize including
feminists of all different strains are
starting to recognize that there are
problems with the sexual culture
recognizing for instance the fact that
porn is really grim
a lot of young people are really unhappy
not having happy sex relationships all
of this i think that pretty much across
the board everyone agrees what everyone
disagrees on is the cause of it
and a common narrative that you'll hear
is from feminism from progressives is
that the sexual revolution was a great
idea
and it was a way of
counteracting
centuries of oppressive patriarchal
repression
and the problem is just that we haven't
i fully implemented it the the the
original idea to free everyone to
prioritize freedom above
all other values
was fabulous the problem is that we
haven't quite yet done it we need more
freedom we need to push that freedom
lever again and again and again until
everything comes right and i think that
was the error i think actually
freedom is not the preeminent value i
think it has to be balanced against
other values
like what
like restraint
oh we don't like that word in the 21st
century we don't no i mean i mean i
guess the point that i'm coming at this
that makes it particularly a feminist
argument is i think that male restraint
is the really important thing
which no one wants to hear well actually
i mean i'll be honest with you i've sort
of certainly in terms of me growing up
the idea that men have to restrain
themselves particularly in relation to
women yeah i mean as part of the trad
sort of way of thinking you know yeah
that that is you know you don't hit
girls for example right because we can
be as equal as we want but there's
certain things that we respect about
each other's differences that we don't
treat each other exactly the same and
everything you know what i mean and
there's other things that you do with
women that you don't do with men and
vice versa that was yeah but but like
you say that
can be experienced by some people is
taking us backwards yeah so how does
that so that circle gets squared or the
square gets circled or whatever it is i
try really hard not to use words like
backwards and forwards actually yeah
because
sort of what i'm saying
which is i guess quite radical is that
the whole the whole idea of progress i
think is nonsense
i don't
use the word progressive to describe
myself even if i agree with people who
call themselves progressives on some
things i don't use that word because i
think the whole idea of history having a
shape
is absurd it's divided from christianity
actually in a way like the the
you know rule headed to the kingdom of
heaven ultimately
i think that history is just about
change and trade-offs and even if you
can sometimes identify some things that
have clearly got better and unlikely to
get better something like infant
mortality let's say none of it's
guaranteed
and
i think that what the sexual revolution
represents is not
progress
it's just a change primarily driven by
technology
and by changes in the economy and by you
know in all other ways material changes
on which the ideological changes are
built
and
yeah i don't think that this simplistic
narrative is right and i don't think
like vocabulary like backwards and
forwards actually illuminates anything
i completely agree with you that it is
very common in all other societies but
our own pretty much
this idea that the
i mean it's chivalry is what you're
describing right it's a horribly
old-fashioned and unfashionable word
chivalry
which has mostly been thrown out because
obviously you know there are good things
that come with it but there are
downsides too it can be patronizing it
can be you know
enfeebling women in various ways
but i think it was a terrible error to
throw it out completely
because when it comes down to it men and
women are different in some really
important ways and i think we have to
find ways of negotiating that rather
than denying it do you not think that it
it might well be that it's all gone a
bit too far do you know what i mean like
it started off you know
progressivism liberalism and it had
these noble values and then you end up
at a place where you talk about how men
and women are the same you go well
that's just scientifically nonsense
it's also the logical endpoint of that
thinking though i think i mean
this this idea of equality this idea of
sameness
right
rather than something like
justice or fairness or other terms that
you might use
i think that there are circumstances in
which it makes sense yeah i think that
saying for instance women should have
access to the professions
is just
i don't i don't think anyone can really
argue with that as being an important
person
if you would not not people i'm friends
with right now
that's fine voting rights all of this
sort of stuff the problem is that those
battles are being won they've been won a
long time ago now
and what we've ended up with
in recent decades
has been a push towards a more radical
push towards sameness
even to the extent of denying the
existence of physical differences
between the sexes
even to the extent of denying the
existence of sexual dimorphism is all
got quite crazy right and i think the
problem that we're now coming up against
is we've reached the kind of bedrock of
biological difference
having chipped away
a lot of sort of
to mix my metaphors having having taken
all the low-hanging fruit in terms of
like
providing women with access to public
life
we reach the point where actually we
can't quite make everyone the same
even if you can sort of pretend to i
mean this is a thing about the modern
world we have
we live in a very very different way
from our ancestors right
and i think that much of what we see
historically as
feminist progress
can be attributed to
material changes right
so
one of the really important ways in
which we differ from our ancestors is
that male physical strength doesn't mean
very much anymore it doesn't matter very
much if you if you live in an
agricultural industrial society
obviously the fact that men are so much
bigger and stronger than women is hugely
important if you live in a knowledge
economy or service economy
it doesn't really matter we can all work
in like gender-neutral offices
and not really notice the differences
between us similarly with the pill which
i argue in the book is like the
technology shock which explains so much
of this history
if you can delay child bearing or if you
can
forego it all together
again you can just operate in the world
pretty much as like a man
you know you might not even go to the
gym you might have like literally no
sort of encounter with the existence of
male physical strength it's quite hard
to like go into a power lifting gym and
not notice right but in general
you can go through life not
observing these differences and it
almost becomes plausible to think that
gender is fluid
and that all of this is just this like
backwards ideas
that for some reason our ancestors
believed
but that's an illusion and i think it's
very brutal and it's built
it's built on technology which is
actually remarkably new
and i think it's that that
that newness i mean
we were women were not able to suspend
their fertility for 99.9 of our species
history you know this is like five
minutes ago in historical terms and i
don't think we've really come to terms
with it which is what i'm trying to do
in the book so what has been the fallout
of the fact that women are able to
suspend their fertility
so i think that the
i call it sexual disenchantment
i've borrowed that term from an american
writer called aaron's barum and he's
borrowed it from max baby sociologist
um so weber was describing the
disenchantment of the natural world it
was a consequence of the
enlightenment that previously people
thought that the natural world had
agency and spirits and specialness and
whatever and then
post scientific revolution we come to
the realization that actually it's just
sort of inner scientific forces
i think that this
same process has happened or at least
rhetorically has happened
in that
it used to be and i think every culture
has elaborate rituals and beliefs around
sex um ways of formalizing sexual
relationships in marriage or you know
similar equivalent
um
you know up until recently
sex within christianity is you know only
permissible within marriage which is a
sacrament it has incredibly special
status incredibly regulated by the state
and by the church
and we've got rid of that mostly
and
now it is quite common to hear people
progressives in particular say that sex
actually doesn't have any
intrinsic value to it it doesn't have
any intrinsic
specialness like if people want to apply
meaning to it on a personal level
they're welcome to
but when it comes down to it it's just a
social interaction you know you can buy
it you can sell it it's fine i don't
think anyone really believes that i
think almost no one actually believes
that and you can tell because people are
extraordinarily inconsistent in applying
this so people who for instance will say
that
sex workers work no problem it's just
like working at mcdonald's
will not apply that to their own
personal lives
or not even apply it to other sort of
similar issues in terms of law and
policy so the example i give in the book
is sex for rent
all of the major political parties in
the uk are united in believing that
landlords who
offer
rooms in exchange
for sexual favors
are all should be breaking the law
they're all united in saying we should
have thermal laws on it this is
particularly post-covered because there
was sort of a rash of landlords doing
this it's the same in other western
countries as well
um
these are exactly the same parties you
know like the lib dems for instance
condemn sex for rent and think we should
decriminalize the sex industry
it's the same thing
you know it's just goods you know being
exchanged for
sexual access is exactly the same thing
and similarly you know people who will
again say the sex workers work that that
um you know really buy into the sexy
disenchantment idea rhetorically
very upset about any perceived sexual
impropriety in their own workplaces
you know
like having any kind of um
being taught you know being touched by a
male colleague being asked out on a date
like that stuff
is very serious and is not at all
comparable to just other forms of
non-sexual interaction
but sex workers work you know and i
think that
i think that inconsistency is a result
of the fact that actually sexual
disenchantment just isn't true
and basically no one really thinks it's
true but the problem is that if you
um are trying to rationalize it all and
you are applying kind of
utility brain to the world
it's quite hard to um
it's quite hard to articulate it's quite
hard to rationalize it comes from a very
visceral place
which is a bit inconvenient if you're
trying to apply that kind of
you know very logical world view the
fact that people have emotional
responses to things that are are
somewhat inconvenient you know but the
truth of it is that people don't feel
that sex is the same as other social
interactions people absolutely feel that
sex has some unique status which is of
course why i mean thinking
from a feminist perspective which is why
rape is so uniquely bad which is why
sexual harassment is so uniquely bad if
you don't think sex is special you can't
think any of those things have special
status either
and i think that that idea of sexual
disenchantment
is bad for everyone but it's really bad
for women
why
partly because of physical
imbalance between the sexes so the fact
that it's only women who get pregnant
women have to suffer the side effects of
hormonal contraception
um women are much smaller and weaker
than men which means that any
heterosexual encounter if you've got a
man or woman alone together the woman's
going to be
almost always the more physically
vulnerable party so there's that kind of
risk inherent to sexual encounters that
women experience that men can't
experience in the same way
there's also the psychological stuff
and that's
more controversial
because the
push towards um
kind of radical equality within feminism
in liberal feminism
has
also included
pushing back very hard against the idea
that there are any innate differences
between the sexes on a psychological
level and some of that is coming from
a good place it is clearly it's clearly
the case that in various periods in
history
pseudoscientific ideas
about women's intellectual inferiority
in particular or emotional inferiority
have been used against women this is
clearly true
um
that does not however mean that those
differences don't exist at all
and actually as decades have gone by and
we've got more and more scientific
research on this it actually becomes
more and more apparent that those
differences do exist on average right
the on average thing is something that
people often can't wrap their heads
around
well they can they just don't want to
well people can when it comes to
something like the advance the example i
give is like you know we say that
germans are on average taller than
people from spain
people are like oh yeah fine no one says
oh but i know a really tall guy from
spain that disproves your thesis you
know this is the nature of bell curves
um
there are all sorts of ways in which the
certain psychological traits differ on
on the bell curve basis between men and
women the one that's most important for
my purposes is the trait that
psychologists call sociosexuality
which is not quite same with sex drive
you can be you know high in one and the
other but sociosexuality is about your
um
desire for casual sex basically how much
you want to have sex with a variety of
people how quickly you want to jump into
bed with someone now look i'm not an
expert
but i'm going to guess men are more
prone to have the higher rate of that
cross-culturally trans historically yes
wow yeah i'm a genius how did i work
that out i know how dare you notice
these things
you know yes i mean anyone who's like
got eyes and lived in the world can tell
that there clearly is that average
difference between men and women even if
there are lots of outliers on an
individual level i mean just because you
know someone sex doesn't mean you know
their level of sociosexuality but at the
population level you see it you see it
for instance in the fact that all
almost all sex buyers everywhere in the
world are male 1
because obviously the people who are is
that tale of high sociosexuality is like
all men
right
um there are i'm going to say something
even more controversial than you but
basically if you want to understand what
men are actually like just look at gay
men right how much sex do they have
and how many partners do they have on
average compared to the average
heterosexual man and you kind of get
like gay men are actually the real men
because they're unrestrained by women
yes yeah absolutely it's really that
simple yeah it's how men would behave if
women weren't a limiting factor exactly
yeah and i mean it's interesting in if
you look at the survey data on gay men
which says quite a lot because it comes
out of like sexual health research and
stuff
what you have is actually like a goodish
proportion of men who are just as
monogamous as lesbians
and you have a lot of men in the middle
and then you have a proportion who are
really promiscuous and because there
isn't the limiting factor of of women
saying no
those men are way more promiscuous than
promiscuous straight men can ever be
because they just have so much more
opportunity um
that you know but that but that
proportion of
like would be permissible straight men
still exists it's just they've got the
complexity of having to deal with female
choice
um which makes the whole heterosexual
you know dating marriage scene that much
more complex so
essentially one of the things you're
talking about which is about apparent to
anyone who's paying attention is that
one of the consequences of many of the
technological changes but also the
cultural technologies that we've now
developed
is that we have a dating market
hate that term but dating market that
caters to men's
predilections much more than it caters
to women's uh and so women who used to
trade this
this is very kind of biological looking
at it so i hope no one's offended by
this but used to trade sex for
commitment right
now are trading sex for the promise of
commitment from men that don't need to
give it anymore yeah is that fair
yeah so that what i uh describe in the
book is what i call sociosexuality gap
the fact that you've got the male bell
curve is that much further towards the
higher than the than the low end and
interestingly one of the responses that
i've got to this to this book from some
readers
is nahangani talking about the sexual
revolution in the 1960s are you talking
about the sex revolution of the first
century
a.d
which is a really interesting historical
comparison which i'm not expert in by
any means but
what happens
during that period is you have roman
sexual norms
yes prize chastity in high status women
but also have vast vast numbers of
prostituted slaves
who men of all classes have access to
basically
and the the the promiscuity and the you
know straightforward violent sexual
abuse
visited by high status men on
women and sometimes men who are lower
status than them it goes completely
unremarked you know harvey weinstein in
that context no one that's an island
he's just behaving completely you know
normally
and what is very strange about the
christian revolution is that christians
are unusual in expecting chastity not
only from women which basically every
culture does and for obvious reasons
because it's about to do with like
paternal certainty
and
they also expected of men
and so the early christians
like basically ask the male the male
bell curve to be dragged down to the
female level
and for men to behave more like women's
actually and to not buy sex and to you
know to not cheat on their wives and all
of this and to expect monogamy which is
what we know
from all sorts of you know server data
loads of other evidence is what women on
average are most likely to want to want
monogamous commitment
and what i think has happened in our
sexual revolution and this recent sexual
revolution is that
the female bell curve has been dragged
up
you know in the expectation now on women
is that they will meet the male demand
for casual sex because obviously
sociosexuality gap has to be bridged
somehow
and
if there aren't enough
women who are outliers and really up for
it
you know there's a kind of
it's you know i say again it's not a
conspiracy
it's just a culture it's a networking
effect that the incentive structure has
changed and it is now mooring women's
interests to
to imitate masculine sexuality and to
have sex like a man
and and moreover to present that as
being feminist
and as a form of empowerment as a form
of you know
self-expression and all of this the
problem you've got is one the physical
imbalance the fact that women are
suffering all of the costs of this
and two
is that psychological
like deep down reluctance that a lot of
women
feel
mostly no yeah
and
you know women are much more likely to
say that they feel really miserable and
depressed after casual sex
to feel used you know all of these kind
of negative emotions coming out of these
encounters
and
this
will sometimes be chalked up to
you know particular men behaving badly
which obviously they do often but
um
will sort of be seen on an individual
level all be ascribed to
um slut-shaming and say well the problem
we've got is that we actually haven't
sufficiently freed ourselves is that
pressing the freedom over again and
again right the problem is we've still
got these hang-ups about sex we still
haven't completely completed the sexual
disenchantment process
women are still like ashamed of their
sexuality
ashamed of being seen as promiscuous etc
that's why women are completely
miserable
i legend that's true
i think the problem we've got is that
actually there's like a
one of the really interesting
differences in sexuality between men and
women is women's sexual disgust
threshold is a lot lower
and that's the sort of thing you can
actually measure
quite empirically because um you can
test the disgust response by looking at
things like
sweating and heart rate and whatever
and
women get much more um easily triggered
into that feeling of like ick
than men do
and there's a biological reason for that
as well yeah to do with the fact that it
is like
getting pregnant is extremely
consequential for women right to the
extent that having having sex is like
potentially one of the most
consequential things you can do as a
woman in terms of the effect that it has
on
on the fact that you then are carrying
this child for nine months and then have
a dangerous labor and then have many
many years of infant care or attempting
um an abortion which until very recently
is invariably very dangerous thing to do
right
or infanticide or you know any number of
horrible options await you if you're
having sex with a man who's gonna who's
gonna leave you
if you become pregnant so they clearly
women are like we've got some very
strongly inbuilt
instincts
which are supposed to protect against
ending up in that kind of situation
basically
we hope you're enjoying this incredible
interview did you know that you can ask
guests your questions that's right when
you join our locals community not only
will you know who we're about to
interview you have the opportunity to
ask them your questions you have the
chance to ask jordan peterson the
co-founder of extinction rebellion nigel
farage douglas murray andrew doyle jeff
norco simon evans larry elder david
badil andrew sullivan megan kelly julia
hartley brewer lord nigel lawson brett
weinstein anaya falarin iman dr david
nutt jimmy dore gad sad blair white
melissa chen trevor phillips ayanne
hersey ali glenn lowry bridgeford i see
jim rickards carl benjamin and so many
more plus we're about to interview some
of the biggest guests
in the world we can't name them just yet
but trust me they're huge
metaphorically speaking not just because
they're american our locals gives you
access to a great community of
like-minded people where you can share
memes and make new and problematic
friends you also get early access to
live shows and we're about to release
details of our tour so you'll want to
know about that as well
on the higher tiers you get monthly
supporter calls and the opportunity to
have a meal or a call with us click the
link below or go to
trigonometry.locals.com
and join the community that's
trigonometry.locals.com
we'll see you there
and i think that what's going on very
often for women that i've spoken to
is that this
one there's this narrative of having sex
like a man is empowering and the belief
that you should give it a go and the
belief moreover that if you don't give
it go it's because you're frigid
and conservative and backwards and all
these bad things
and two the feeling that they sort of
have to because the
assumption very often
is that you have to sort of run the
gauntlet of hookup culture in order to
find a partner
that you can't possibly i mean one of
the things that i advise in the book
which i've
i'm told is a completely crazy thing to
advise is to hold off on having sex for
a few months in the first few months of
a relationship
because
it's a good way of testing whether he's
serious about you it's a good way of not
being clouded by hormones if you're
trying to like
vet a partner
um
and i hear from women i'm like what are
you talking about what kind of man is
going to wait three months
to have sex a man that's actually really
into you i'd imagine but it feels
impossible it feels like if you go out
there on the daisy market and you have
that restriction applied
that you're like you can't compete well
you can't compete
with you're not going to get as many
dates but yeah if the but the point of
dating isn't to get a date presumably
right
and by the way the one thing before you
jump in frances i would add is i
actually i don't know what what the
studies show but i would argue that this
isn't good for men either and it doesn't
make men happy either because actually
men also feel disgust about hookup
culture and sex
it might be like a bit of a status boost
and a temporary fleeting moment of joy
or whatever but actually
i don't think in the long run that makes
men happy either i completely agree i
opened the book by talking about marilyn
monroe and hugh hefner as the like
perfect examples of the sexual
revolution and the desperate effect it
has on men and women the fact that she
had this
i mean she had a pretty consistently
miserable life for all of her beauty and
fame and wealth um and she died
prematurely as everyone knows from
substance abuse and so on
whereas you have now had a had a grand
old time but by the time he was elderly
he actually was a really pathetic figure
and he never you know he he enjoyed the
period of youthful promiscuity and being
famous and glamorous and all of this
but actually his final decades were
quite tragic and he ended up not ever
having
you know the source the thing that
people actually invariably find real
meaning from which is
family and intimacy and you know all of
the the good long-term things because he
just had this like extended adolescence
right up until his final days
and the problem as well is when it comes
to the dating apps is that there's only
a few uh a select selection of men
who are actually yeah you know who are
living the playboy dream yeah exactly
and then the other men aren't getting a
look in because it's all superficial and
it's all about how you look in
photographs so then all the women are
after this
tiny sliver of men yeah the hypergamy
thing who therefore don't have to commit
yes yes what's really interesting about
this is that um
i said my first degree was anthropology
most societies on the anthropological
record have been polygamous
in the
high status men take on multiple wives
and then lower status men have have none
um almost no one is polyandrous no
matter what sort of like the some second
wave um
writers try to sort of imagine these
like amazing matriarchal design no no no
human history is fairly clear on this um
polygamy is the norm
about 20 have been monogamous including
clearly
our society in all
christian societies and one of the
puzzle one of the things what
anthropologists call the puzzle of
monogamous marriage is why on earth that
would ever come about because clearly
polygamous societies suit the high
status men
best and those men are generally the
people who have the most influence in
setting the terms of of society and laws
and all of this so why not they accept a
system which basically restricts them
and the answer seems to be because
monogamy is a really good system in all
sorts of completely empirical ways right
monogamous societies tend to be more
economically productive partly because
high status men instead of investing
money in more wives invest money in
things like businesses and take you on
employees and you know all sorts of like
things that are good for economic growth
um
has lower rates of child abuse and
domestic abuse because
households with co-wives tend to be have
a lot of conflict for obvious reasons
um as lower crime
because you don't have this pool
of unmarried and unhappy
you know in cells basically right who
are high on testosterone and very low on
responsibility
um who are much more likely to do sort
of opportunistic crimes so there's all
sorts of ways in which monogamy
yes it restricts
you know that that top slice of playboys
who i mean basically that's what they're
living on tinder right they're not
marrying these women obviously but
they're having like
uh
simultaneous relationships or
or like back-to-back brief monogamous
relationships they're like accumulating
lots of wives
and it's great for them in the short
term
it's rubbish for the other men and it's
also rubbish for the women because you
end up with women who actually really
want to have
like
loving intimate monopolist relationships
and they don't feel like they can
get access to them because that's not
how the culture is arranged and like yes
you can say no i'm not gonna have sex
with you for three months you can say
that and i do think like
it's better to do that and then not
like
be a co-wife of a playboy
than it is to
to just like go without
but it's difficult because that's not at
all what the you know incentive
structures put in place encourage you to
do
what's really interesting and just like
proving this this this
population level difference between male
and female sexuality is if you look at
university campuses which are reasonably
closed environments people have
having a lot of relationships with each
other and don't have very much to do
um campuses where men outnumber women so
women are the rarer sex and therefore
have more power to set the terms i know
it's so like brutal is talking economic
terms but that like it has a lot of
explanatory power
they tend to have more monogamous
relationships a culture of of
of monogamy they're saying the terms
because they're setting the terms and
then on campuses where you have more
um women than men the men of the rarer
sex then you have more hong kong culture
because these are the average
preferences between the sexes and this
is how you see it map out
but hang on haven't we evolved beyond
the need for this
that's what i've been told you know
we're polyamorous now aren't we i mean
what's so interesting right about
polyamory is that
you know on the sexual disenchantment
thing like the the polyamorous community
are desperate to like make sexual
disenchantment true but you go onto any
platform on you know reddit twitter
whatever and where people are talking
discussing their experiences as a
polyamory and you always come across
people who are desperately jealous
and really struggling with it and being
like i know i'm being really irrational
i know i'm being really old-fashioned i
need to like free my mind from the
shackles of
whatever like monogamous tyranny but
they can't quite do it because actually
it comes down to it and we are
we can unlike other animals you know we
are able to overcome our natural
instincts a bit like you know look
around we clearly live extremely
different lives from those of our
ancestors and other
other primates
but
like there's a limit there comes a point
where actually there's like a there is a
bedrock of biology
and it's actually really really hard to
resist your instincts to that degree and
you will just end up unhappy if you keep
plugging away at it do you know what
when i visualize the process that i sort
of think about we're discussing here and
more generally when it applies to other
issues it feels to me like
because
i have to say this every time we talk
about like i come from a liberal back
but it does feel like and i i value
freedom to me that is a very important
value i've written a whole book about it
right
but also i feel it's almost like we've
sat there for decades sowing at the
chains that we thought were constraining
us but actually in the process realized
that we were actually also so in the
branch that we've been sitting on at the
same time yeah and what we've ended up
with is a lot more freedom to fall down
to the ground and smash into it
that's sort of how it feels like to me
do you see what i'm saying yeah
chesterton spence right it's the gk
chesterton's idea that you you know a
reformer comes along and sees a fence in
the middle of the field and it's like
why not is this there i'm going to tear
it down
and then the conservative says
if you don't know what the point of the
fence is you're the last person you
should be tearing it down because who
knows what it is that the fences what
what what task the defense is performing
and i think that we are kind of learning
that the hard way a bit as a culture
like there were certain
there were reasons for some of these
things
and this is one of the problems you get
with the progress narrative that if
if your whole view of history
is premised on the idea that people in
the past were like bad and stupid
and that every year you know things get
better and people get wiser and whatever
and like until five minutes ago you see
all this stuff about like do you
remember that rash of um op-eds about
how the sitcom friends was like possibly
problematic yes you know
it's like 20 30 years ago right and
we've already and we're already
condemning people who are still who are
not even in middle age to like the
dustbin of history in terms of their in
terms of their ideology i mean this is
so rapid this level of like regeneration
and level of like reinventing having to
reinvent society constantly and also i
think
there's a hubris to it as well you know
the idea that we should be able to just
design society on the back of an
envelope and that's going to be
better than anything that's gone before
i think in reality what we're actually
faced with is thinking about
looking at real other societies
and comparing them
because these are actually the like
realistic options available to us the
utopias have never existed
and i think the problem
with
some feminist efforts in this regard
like towards communal child rearing for
instance
or political lesbianism i mean it does
work for some people like political
lesbianism to be fair is completely
internally coherent
like if if if you look at the
sociosexuality gap
and you look at the male propensity for
aggression on average and all of this
stuff and say i want none of it
like
you can do that i see i see the
reasoning the problem is that we then
have
what max 100 years and the species dies
out it's like it's like anti-nationalist
in an extremely profound way
um if we want to make it work and also
if we want to recognize the fact that
um you know
most people are heterosexual
most people want to and will become
parents
you know like the the nature of human
life necessitates connection and
dependency we can't just operate as
these like advertised individuals and
hope for the best
then we have to find a way of managing
those connections and dependency and i
think that
the my last chapter in the book and
probably probably my most controversial
chapter is called marriage is good
where i make the feminist argument for
monogamous marriage
as actually of all the of all the
systems we've experimented with as the
most durable and the most likely to
defend the interests
of
women and mothers
in particular
back in the kitchen
to me the the the really tragic aspect
of all of this is that a lot of these
people who would identify as
progressives and say there is no
difference between men and women blah
blah blah blah blah
there is a cap on female fertility that
men simply don't have yeah
and once you get to a certain age it
becomes more and more and more difficult
so this idea that you can have it all
you're actually robbing a lot of women
of the chance of becoming a mother which
is an awful thing
it's surprising isn't it how how little
progress we've made in that regard
like the i say progress advisedly like
the technological interventions
which we've we've tried really hard to
use to lengthen the female fertility
window they're not very good ivf is not
very good
you know it actually is surprisingly
ineffective
um
surrogacy is an ethical disaster right
like the all of these efforts to try and
tame mother nature and and basically
give people absolute freedom and because
this is what you come down to in the end
eventually if your your preeminent value
is freedom
you are at some point going to encounter
like biological
impediments to your freedom and you have
to try and chip away at them like if
that's what the ideology directs you to
do
and
i mean what that means in practice is
sometimes using technology with all of
its unintended consequences you know all
new technologies have trade-offs
sometimes using the bodies of poorer
people that's what the surrogacy
industry does right um
or sometimes trying to you know master
our
our monkey brains right try and do
things which we we feel like we ought to
be able to do for you know whether that
be
have sex like a man whatever it might be
and then suffering the emotional
fallout from that
and yeah the fertility window is one of
them it's not going anywhere and it is
another source of sexual asymmetry to
the extent that particularly because
women uh tend to date men who are a
little bit older than them
so so you know women entering their
thirties and so on have that have that
sense of
um time constraint that the men just
don't
and so the playboys
they can you know they can have a whale
of a time for quite a long period before
they have to start worrying about
whether they've
ruined their chances of having a family
but then they're stringing along these
women
who you know wasting time
and coming out of it really really
bitter and miserable as a consequence
yeah
so
where does this go louise because
it's i i
you see if we were a self-contained
society that lived on a planet and it
was just us
we could
do all sorts of [ __ ] that we want
but when you're talking about for
example political lesbianism in addition
to all the things that you talk about
there's another factor here which is
there are societies that don't have such
a big problem with toxic masculinity and
all these other nonsense and as someone
who actually thinks the west other than
some of the craziness that is going on
is pretty great
and worth existing and defending and
living and so on one of my concerns has
been that
a lot of these
so-called progressive changes actually
make us a lot weaker and more vulnerable
and more appealing for domination
takeover by hostile cultures
so
where how do we sort of address some of
these things and to make sure that a men
and women are happy because i agree with
you completely what's happening is not
good especially for women but also for
men
but also how do we address it at the
level of society so we actually are able
to defend ourselves project our power
abroad have a confidence in our society
that we seem to be losing because we're
constantly beating ourselves up about
how we're not utopian enough
yeah
great
[Laughter]
so i think there is possibly a sexual
counter evolution on the way
and i say that with some trepidation
because i obviously think that the
current scenario isn't good
and i think that there has been a sort
of
the swing towards greater and greater
freedom
has had all sorts of costs and you know
all of this that we've talked about
i also recognize about that a sexual
counter revolution could be seriously
ugly depending on depending on what it
looked like all counter revolutions are
ugly precisely yeah so i mean what
you're seeing a bit among um
gen z
is i think a bit of a
a bit of a bifurcation you've got some
gen z who you know absolutely love like
gender fluidity and and
and sex positivism and all this stuff
you've also got a surprising swing to
the right because normally what happens
in recent decades is that every
generation gets kind of more left-wing
but that's not true actually of this one
and you've also i think got a definite
swing back against porn culture
not always from
the sort of feminist ethics perspective
not always because i think everyone
knows that the way that porn is produced
is really not fair trade
but because um
coming from like groups like nofap
that see
porn as deleterious to men which it is
but you know that's not the only
objection
um
i you know there are all sorts of other
like i think on the whole that's sort of
promising but i'm also aware that there
are lots of other ways in which you
could have a sexual counter revolution
islamism is one example
um
a move back towards
fundamentalist christianity i think
probably not in the uk but definitely in
the us i mean we're speaking just after
roe was overturned and you've got
various states that have introduced some
really draconian
laws on
abortion that go way beyond what the
modal american things i mean the modal
american actually is pretty much agreed
like first trimester is okay
and then only with serious medical
problems or rape or whatever um
whereas you've got some state
legislatures that have gone
far beyond that which is i think always
the risk when you when you've
overreached well right if you're out
with in the middle of the streets with
pink hair celebrating every abortion
that happens you're gonna you're gonna
do that yeah people are gonna react to
that i think particularly with social
media because you've got this amazing
capacity to
um
signal boost the crazies on both sides
absolutely which inflames the crazies on
both sides and then you end up with this
really extreme and dangerous
polarization and you can totally see
that with with with sex happening but
see what i would argue there as well i
mean i do agree with you i think both
sides of the culture or whatever is
people from
one side
laughing and mocking the people who are
crazy on the other side but what you
also have is a cowardice on both sides
about absolutely speaking out against
their own extremists yeah and that's
that's actually for us that's where
we're coming from you know from our
perspective we were both sort of
left-ish comedians going what the [ __ ]
has happened to this industry and the
world yeah where like comedians have to
like censor themselves and whatever
but people don't want to do that
politicians don't do that they don't
call out you know if you're on the right
you're not going to call out the people
who stormed january the 6th because you
know that you're going to lose a portion
of your voter base and likewise on the
left you're not calling out all these
social justice crazies yeah you're not
you're not calling out blm burning down
cities you're not calling all that out
you're just staying silent and then of
course people are going to assume
that you agree with it
and then they're going to push back
against it in ways that i agree with you
completely is going to throw the baby
out with the bath water and it's one of
the reasons i wrote the book because you
know i'm coming from
i don't know i'm still on the left it's
a complicated question but you know i'm
coming from i grew up reading the
guardian i work for the new statesman
and the daily mail like i
i still feel a great affinity
with left
and as you say there is a complete
mismanagement of the left's crazies and
similarly on the right it's a completely
symmetrical process and i think the
problem with i think that there has been
a massive
swing much too far in the like libertine
direction and i think that the
i think the
the counter swing
i think feminists have to participate in
it
in the sense that if if we say for
instance that
um if we don't permit any heterodoxy
whatsoever within feminism if you squish
any
like
any any any contrarian voice
and you reject
any efforts to try and like negotiate
this process then you end up with no
no female voices in it i mean this is
one of the things for instance has
happened in evolutionary psychology the
evolution psychology was condemned
by feminists you know many decades ago
as being inherently sexist
and there aren't any women now writing i
mean no they're sorry there are but it's
like it's basically a no-go zone for
feminists just to just to voice your
support of evolution psychology as i do
is it's like a very eccentric thing to
do
and you get a lot of flack for it as i
have obviously got inevitably i know i
would um
but then what happens is that you don't
have a role in this discipline there's
there are no feminist voices within it
the most you know the most um
the most sexist voices can just run
right
basically and i think that yeah there
has to be this effort at sort of
not just indulging in the status games i
think that so much of what goes on in
this polarization process is people
don't want to criticize their in groups
they don't want to be
tarred for whatever misdemeanor
like you know traitorous misdemeanor
because you get punished so much more
for being a traitor than you do oh yeah
for being an enemy right yeah um
they're so concerned with their their
status within the group that they tell
lies
because it's the way that you maintain
that status and i think that we can't do
that anymore it's too serious yeah
moving on i want to talk to you about
pornography because we live in a culture
now where pornography is becoming ever
more mainstream and you can talk to a
wealth of commentators and indeed some
people who worked in that industry who
will say what's the problem
you know this is a natural act people
watching it consenting adults blah blah
blah so what is the problem with
pornography i think those voices are
getting a little bit more sparse
actually i mean yeah absolutely you can
you can easily find people who often
have a financial stake in the industry
who say that it's fine you know pornhub
worked pretty hard to
project an ethical image
through various
schemes whatever like there's an effort
i think it's sort of failing though i
think that the
particularly from the gen z
the the kids who've actually grown up on
this stuff and who had smartphones when
they were 11 or whatever and had access
to all the world horrors in a computer
in their pockets right i think that they
recognize
that this is there's something really
dystopian about porn
um i spoke at the oxford union earlier
this year on on a motion to do with
porn
and i won very unexpectedly because i
thought that i thought i'd be
slaughtered by all of these you know sex
positive kids and i did get some very
hostile questions from the floor
but i won the vote
and i think that's because actually
there is a
recognition from those who've lived it
the porn culture is
dreadful i mean i think porn culture is
the only people who are really profiting
from porn of the people actually on
their platforms who are invariably men
there's this quote i use in the book
that you know as tech comes to dominate
all of our lives including our intimate
lives you end up with this situation
where some people are above the
algorithm and some people are below the
algorithm being influenced by by it and
porn is one of those things where almost
everyone is below the algorithm
you know obviously if you are actually
um involved in creating it
consensually or non-consensually right
clearly you are influenced by the
industry
but also people who use it and also just
anyone who has sex with anyone who's
ever used it because it has this way
particularly with young minds
of
of molding people's sexuality
i think there's this there's this
false model
of sexuality which is sort of linked to
sexual disenchantment where
you understand sexual desire to be a
fixed quantity both in terms of
um quantity and also quality
and that what porn does or other sexual
relationships do whatever is it just
sort of provides a vent it just like
provides a release for that sexual
energy and like you return to
equilibrium
but actually what's what's clear and
what has been made clear actually by the
experiment of online porn is that that's
not true like there are
um
watching porn inscribes certain arousal
patterns
in the brain you know and and the pawn
platforms are designed
to do that they're designed to lead the
most compulsive users down this kind of
rabbit hole
of
seeking out more and more extreme
stimulation stuff that no one would ever
have thought of
you know if left to their own devices in
a age before the internet even the age
before magazines or whatever
no one would have dreamed up
some of the absolutely absurd stuff that
you can find on the internet for porn
and this is because
the internet you know provides you
access to the like the global hive mind
but not just that it's because
there is profit to be made from this
stuff
there's a minority of men i think it's
like two percent of men who watch porn
seven hours or more a week
and they and they actually account for
like a very large proportion of of the
porn industry's viewers viewers and
profits like there's a burrito
distribution right
they're not a happy group of people
like if you're watching that much porn
you
you can't but really damage your real
life relationships it is very likely
you'll end up
with erectile dysfunction i mean
erectile dysfunction rates among young
men have just skyrocketed in the last 20
years and i think there's this is like a
very obvious cause of it
um
it's very hard to have like a normal
sexual relationship
um you're very likely to end up watching
really weird stuff
including child sexual abuse images i
mean there are
psychologists and and clinical
psychiatrists who are
who are treating
men who've been found guilty of child
sexual abuse image possession
saying that actually they're seeing men
now who would not previously have ended
up doing this because they wouldn't
they're not like
um
they're not true pedophiles in the sense
that this isn't like their sexual
orientation what they've ended up doing
is just go you know clicking and
clicking and clicking and clicking
and ending up watching the most depraved
things
imaginable because they've got sucked
into this you know it's called um limbic
capitalism is a term that's used to
describe
this this area of capitalism doesn't
just apply to porn obviously it applies
to like
uh junk food social media you know
things like apps the reason that apps
are often
uh brightly colored and kind of
glistening you know how they make them
glisten is because it makes your brain
think that it's water and fresh fruit
like those are
those of stimuli that we find really
really attractive
um all of this stuff is designed to like
to like hit you here you know in the bit
of the brain that actually you're not
necessarily consciously aware of and
porn's a really really good example of
olympic capitalism because the whole
thing is just set up to arouse the human
body
to the extent that it actually almost
disables your moral reasoning because
going back to sexual disgust
being sexually aroused
partially disables your disgust response
because obviously to have sex you have
to get close to people and you know
normally you're disgusted by strangers
right like being in someone's armpit on
the tube is disgusting but clearly to
have sex you have to override that so
there's a there's a like an exchange
process
and just the disgust response is really
closely linked to moral intuition
so it basically means if you're really
sexually aroused as the
platforms are designed to make you so
you can't
reason morally
in the same way that you normally would
and so a lot of people including women
who use porn will talk about
um
going to these platforms watching stuff
that
like in normal times they would think
was appalling like obvious acts of
coercion whatever
and then they orgasm and then they push
the laptop away and they're like oh my
god
but they come back and do it
because the whole thing is
designed in that way and i think that to
compare you know people will talk about
like oh what about erotic art and what
about you know magazines of the 60s or
whatever i mean i mean there were
clearly problems with magazines of the
60s but it's a completely different base
it's completely different based and i
think that allowing the online porn
industry to run rampant
has just been this ground experiment
particularly on the world's children
and i think as a result of coming in
it's becoming clear
that this was a really really
dangerous experiment
[Music]
hey constantine do you love trigonometry
i'm from russia i cannot love anything
apart from vodka miserable literature
and a horrendous downfall of my people
but yes i find trigonometry satisfactory
and do you like live shows of course but
only if it's check of play about
collapse of russian aristocracy as they
face death and obscurity before the
glorious might of the proletariat and
the beautiful revolution
okay mate well if you like trigonometry
live shows then get your credit card out
for the lads because we're coming to the
edinburgh festival this august we have
only booked two shows august 6th and 7th
because if we do more the comedy
industry will treat us like the tsars
and execute us that's right we're going
to be in edinburgh for two days only
saturday's guest is andrew doyle which
is sure to sell out our other guest is
leo curse which means when nicola
sturgeon hears about it she'll ban us
from scotland herself tickets are sure
to sell out and when they're gone
they're gone click on the link below and
we'll see you in edinburgh on the 6th
and 7th of august at the gilded balloon
teviet come and see us before hordes of
left-wing comedians try to put us in
gulag
louise one other issue uh that a lot of
the women who watch our show have always
wanted us to talk about you you touched
on earlier which is surrogacy yeah i
don't really know much about it i've
never really had to think about it
but uh but as we know with some other
conversations that women like to have
women are really angry about it so
what's going on there
i mean i think that the problem is there
are a bunch of problems with surrogacy
um
that surrogacy is basically where
someone is carrying your child for you
right yeah yeah yeah i mean normally
paid but not necessarily so there's
there's there's so-called altruistic
surrogacy
um which doesn't involve payment in this
country at the moment the law is that
you're not allowed to pay someone
for surrogacy and it happens because you
are physically unable to or you don't
wish to carry and give birth to a child
and you want someone else to do it for
you those were those the two reasons
okay and there are also two
subcategories in the sense that there's
traditional surrogacy which involves um
the surrogate's own egg right
and then there's uh gestational
surrogacy where you have an egg donor
whether that be from a commission you
know one of the commissioning parents or
from
a third party okay um so they basically
put a fertilized egg in you yeah so
you're just a carrier and that's it it's
not your dna yeah yeah i mean one of the
reasons that that's happened is because
traditional surrogacy arrangements
um the surrogate is just obviously the
mother in every possible way yeah right
except
legally and so you ended up with a lot
of disputes over custody because
surrogates changed their minds like
surprisingly often surrogates changed
their minds you say that i mean i i like
i said i've never thought about this
issue before but my wife has had a baby
well we had a baby a couple of months
ago
and i i can't imagine
like
counting the baby over no yeah i know i
know i heard exactly the same thing
because i've got a 14 month old oh okay
yes thank you and yeah i had exactly the
same like
you can sort of get it in theory that
before you know if you've not actually
gone through the process
once you've gone through it you think
yeah because your emotional bond to that
child is just you know unless you know
clearly there are cases where say women
have to post traumatic
stress from the birth or they have
postnatal depression or you know like
clearly sometimes cases where it goes
wrong and the bonding doesn't happen as
it ought to
but in a healthy relationship you know
that bond is so strong and it has to be
i mean again it's going back to
evolutionary thing like
newborn babies completely helpless they
absolutely need well you've carried this
creature inside you for that like i feel
sick thinking about it to be honest
right now yeah that's probably why i've
never thought about it before yeah it is
awful actually yeah yeah and that to me
i mean there are a lot of objections you
can make to the surrogacy industry the
fact that uh what often happens is
you've got like seriously poor women
kept in basically like
farm yard condition you know in in the
third world creating babies for people
in the first world it's like serious
handmaid's tale
um there are some really really really
horrible examples there are also
examples which are not like that much
more sort of
you know
organic surrogacy where you have you
know corrupt
grasping right yeah where you have say
altruistic arrangements or whatever
um or women who are paid
better like america has
a flourishing surrogate industry in
states like california
so how much these women get paid in like
places like california do you know i
think potentially quite a lot and i i i
don't know the numbers on my head like
sometimes quite a lot um
and often these women who don't
necessarily have
a lot of other options i mean it's quite
common for instance for women whose
husbands are in the military yeah to do
this because there's sort of money you
can earn distract for cash and it's a
sort of money you can earn
like you know at home i mean it's a it's
a seriously weird job in the sense that
you do it literally all of the time
and you have
like
none of the employment conditions you
would expect from literally anything
else it's a very strange job but you
know
um
there is obviously like a radical
feminist a marxist case to be made that
this is the most disgusting thing like
form of
exploitation at the biological level
that you can imagine and there's clearly
a a huge power imbalance
based on money
i agree with that but to me and it
partly comes down to just the experience
of having a baby myself i just think
that the idea of setting out to sever
the maternal bond you know obviously
sometimes the maternal bond has to be
broken you know if you've got like
a child that has to be taken into care
right
it's a tragedy
it sometimes has to happen or if you
know your mother dies and the baby has
to be raised by someone else you know
these these
people make the best of it you can find
ways of getting through but obviously
you know it's an awful thing no one
wants it to happen but with surrogacy
that's the point you set out
for a woman to carry a baby to term give
birth this baby and then
break that bone potentially never see
the baby ever again and i just think
it is that thing isn't it of like
denying our animal selves
like resisting the most intense emotions
that we can have as human beings and you
know one of the most the strongest
emotions you can have is maternal love
and i just think that the mutilation of
that is terrible and it applies no
matter the circumstances it applies to
altruistic as well i mean there is some
situation so you know say a sister is
carrying a baby for her sister or
something it's
very complicated clearly in terms of
family relationships you know maybe if
she's continuing to have a relationship
with her
child slash niece or nephew
that's like the best possible version of
it that's almost never what it actually
looks like though
that is
i mean
no i'm not a woman i don't know blah
blah but to give birth to something and
then just hand it away like it's a
parcel
yeah like it's commodity i mean it's
human trafficking isn't it because
you're not actually being paid for the
pregnancy you're being paid to have the
baby over and i suppose this is one of
the solutions to the fact that we need
to extend the fertility window yeah this
is this is exactly this is a great
example of just like chipping away at
any limits on human freedom
rather than saying look life is tragic
sometimes
you know i have i have huge
sympathy for people who can't have
children their biological children for
whatever reason
but also you know if if
if the impediment to your
freedom your desire
is
you know
the breaking the maternal bonds for
money
i just think that is
i think that's too much of a cost to pay
but also the other thing that i think
about here is the fact that actually
for a lot of people and i see this and i
don't know what the data is but
anecdotally i see this for a lot of
women the fact that they're not able to
have a child biologically is a
consequence of choices that have been
made prior and quite often under many of
the things we've been talking about in
this interview yeah where society has
told you that you can have things that
actually you can't have yeah yeah it's
usually age-related facilities right and
and in that process you've pursued
things that don't have the long-term
outcomes that you actually want
because you've bought into the idea that
we live in a world that we don't live in
it's tragic actually louise what we're
talking about it really is and it
worries me a lot because you know i was
saying to you before we started this
interview most of my family are female
have three younger sisters i have a ton
of female cousins it's like me and my
dad are the only ones holding the for
masculinity just about in the family
and when i talk to them these problems
are manifest in many of their lives not
all but in many of their lives and that
that's in russia and ukraine and armenia
that's not here in the west where it's
far more advanced yeah
it worries me a lot
this stuff it really does
so
other than the evil right-wing backlash
that you're expecting how how do those
of us who are trying to be sensible
about all of this
make efforts to address it
i mean
there is a lot to be said for some of
the norms that we've torn down
not all of them by any means but you
know marriage as an example
there was a reason for this stuff
you know
marriage has has
has proved itself to be
a particularly good basis but you're
talking like
i mean you're going well he's in the
ground now and we'll miss him i know
yeah but
yeah yeah how do you resurrect this
stuff well is it resurrect is there
something new that we have to um you
know find a way
to to maybe it's not about resurrecting
marriage just acknowledging that it's
good like
there's got to be a way right because
because i mean let's be objective if
we're pretty screwed if we don't find
a way through this and you have a child
i have a child they're going to be
growing up in this world i don't want
them to be
experiencing the stuff that young people
are experiencing now yeah there's got to
be a way right i take hope in the fact
that i have had so many responses to
this book along the lines of like thank
god for saying you're saying this that
i've been thinking this all this time
and i think that i think it is possible
despite all the material constraints
just by all you know i think that when
everyone is simultaneously thinking
something and not saying it and then
suddenly you're allowed to say it i
think things can change really quickly
there's that you know there's that
tipping point where actually it becomes
permissible
and i think that there has been a
feeling
that
if you voice any of this you're going to
get smackdown you're going to get
accused of being a you know
religious conservative whatever which is
one of the reasons i felt the need to
write the book because i i
um
i have like a i have a strong enough
record of on feminist campaigning and
frontline work and you know that i i'm
not afraid of people
saying that
i'm i'm afraid i'm not a real feminist
or whatever because i just sort of laugh
it off so i feel as though
i felt i felt a bit of responsibility to
to put my head above the parapet and say
it and have got a lot of criticism
but i have equally also got a lot of
positive responses particularly you know
from readers
um
saying
yeah this is this is what we're all
thinking
so that's my little glimmer of hope i'm
not generally a very optimistic person
but
there we go
thank you so much for coming on the show
thank you uh before we talk about
everything else about where to find you
online and all of that and before bonus
locals questions of course of course
we always finish with the final question
which is what's the one thing we're not
talking about that we really should be
i'm gonna mess up the the optimistic
note that we tried to end on sex robots
i think sex robots are on their way
i think they shouldn't be
and i think there's a very like pro male
reason to say that they shouldn't be i
mean the concern for sex about sex
robots has generally been from a
feminist perspective the idea that
you're kind of training
um men who use them to think of women as
being an inert and whatever like
encouraging violence i'm sure that's
probably true
for me though i think the problem
one of the really big problems with sex
robots as well as that is that
you've got
skyrocketing amounts of young men who
are not having sex relationships at all
who are going into their 20s or even 30s
remaining virgins hooked on porn you
know all of this
and more than that also just not living
productive lives you know not holding
down jobs not like
not making any progress in their lives
um just stuck in this kind of miserable
adolescence and i think sex robots would
just supercharge that if they ever
became you know affordable
for these men and became
um
like sufficiently convincing which they
are on track to
because what what sex robots basically
do to the like
to the monkey brain you know to the
evolved mind is they is they give you a
completely false sense of like your own
success in the world
you can be
you know you don't have to go to the gym
you don't have to clean your room you
don't have to have a job you don't have
to own a house you don't have to do any
of the things that will actually make
you a happier and more enriched human
being because you've got your sex robot
who will give you the impression that
actually you're a stud
right
and i think that there's a it's like
super stimuli
times a million right the sex robot is
like the most
the most perfect encapsulation of that
of that phenomenon and that risk
and
yeah i don't i think that we need to
i think we need to ban them basically
like whatever mechanism is necessary
very interesting
well
it's been a positive optimistic
uplifting interview but louise you know
what i have to say i really first of all
respect you for writing the book
uh i really am very very impressed with
how careful you've thought about these
things and how much you have to say and
uh i do hope that you continue to write
on these issues and we'd love to have
you back again next time you've got a
book out or anything you you
particularly feel like you have to say
uh i actually think that
some of the stuff we talked about today
is probably going to be shaping the
world for for for many decades to come
in very powerful ways
and a lot of us are going to have to
think extra carefully about how to
navigate all that if we're going to get
to a better place which you don't think
we're going to get to anyway
so thanks for coming on uh the book is
of course the case against the sexual
revolutions where can sexual revolution
rather where can people find you online
and follow your work if they want to get
more depressed than where they are so i
also write for the new statesman and i
write for daily mail
great are you are you on twitter i am on
twitter uh at louise underscore m
underscore perry perfect uh louise thank
you so much for coming on and thank you
guys for watching and listening we'll
see you uh on locals for a couple of
bonus questions from you followees but
uh in the meantime thank you for
watching and we'll see you very soon
with another brilliant episode like this
one or raw show and for those of you who
like your trigonometry on the go it's
also available as a podcast take care
and see you soon guys
[Music]
how does a single woman find a guy who
isn't totally porn adult
[Music]